>> Laura: WE HAVE A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
'S GRAND JURY RETURNS A 16 COUNT
FEDERAL INDICTMENT AGAINST
"EMPIRE" ACTOR JUSSIE SMOLLETT
FOR HIS HATE CRIME HOAX.
JOINING US NOW RAYMOND A BEST
SELLING AUTHOR.
--.
TALK ABOUT A WHIPLASH WITH
PEOPLE THINKING MAGA PEOPLE WERE
GOING IN TO LOOK FOR BLACK MEN
TO BEAT UP.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING OUT
DEFENDING HIM.
THIS IS DEVASTATING.
16 COUNT FEDERAL GRAND JURY.
IT'S NOT ONLY FALSELY REPORTING
A HATE CRIME.
THERE ARE OTHER CHARGES.
THIS LOOKS REALLY BAD FOR HIM.
SHOULD HE BE OFF THE SHOW
PERMANENTLY?
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
WHEN THE ENTIRE NATION IS
TRANSFIXED, YOU COULD HAVE
TRIGGERED RIOTS.
THAT'S WHAT THE POLICE SAID ON
THIS SHOW.
>> INVITING HATE.
>> Laura: DIVIDING PEOPLE
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THE FEAR THAT THAT PUT IN THE
HEARTS AND CONSCIOUSNESS OF
AMERICANS, ESPECIALLY MINORITY
AMERICANS.
AND ROPEING IN TWO OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU WRITE A CHECK.
>> IT'S A CONSPIRACY TO CREATE
HATE AND TO DRIVE MORE HATE.
IT'S JUST WHAT WE DIDN'T NEED.
IN THE POP CULTURE AND IN OUR
POLITICS.
>> Laura: A LOT MORE TO GET TO
ON "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" WITH THE
CRAZINESS.
THERE ARE CALLS TO STOP PLAYING
MICHAEL JACKSON'S MUSIC AFTER
THE AIRING OF THAT EXPLOSIVE
HUGE HIT THAT HBO DOCUMENTARY
LEAVING NEVERLAND.
WHAT IS THE STORY?
>> MILLION DOLLARS IS THE STORY.
SONY JUST PAID $250-MILLION
DOLLARS TO DISTRIBUTE ALL OF
MICHAEL JACKSON'S CATALOG.
THERE IS A POPULAR VEGAS CIRCQUE
DESOLEIL SHOW WITH HIS SONGS AND
IMAGE.
TWO VICTIMS ALLEGED HORRIFIC
SEXUAL ABUSE AT JACKSON'S HAND.
ALL OF THAT IS IN PERIL.
THESE VICTIMS NEW MICHAEL
JACKSON AS MINORS AND SOUGHT
MONEY FROM THE JACKSON ESTATE IN
2013 AND THEIR GAMES WERE THROWN
OUT.
THEY TESTIFIED FOR JACKSON WHEN
HE FACED SIMILAR ALLEGATIONS IN
2005.
AT THAT TIME THEY CLAIMED THEY
WERE NEVER ABUSED.
NOW EVEN CORY FELDMAN IS BACKING
AWAY FROM HIS SUPPORT FOR THE
KING OF POP.
WATCH.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE PERCEIVED
AS I AM HERE TO DEFENDER
MICHAEL.
I CAN NO LONGER DO THAT.
I CAN'T IN GOOD CONSCIOUSNESS
DEFEND ANYONE WHO IS BEING
ACCUSED OF SUCH HORRENDOUS
CRIMES.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING.
EVEN THE SIMPSONS PRODUCERS ARE
PULLING BACK AN EPISODE IN WHICH
MICHAEL JACKSON'S VOICE WAS
FEATURED.
>> Laura: AND OPRAH INTERVIEWED
JACKSON.
>> IN 1993 AND INTERVIEWED HIS
FAMILY WHEN HE DIED.
NOW THEY ARE CASHING ON HIM WHEN
HE IS DEAD.
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
THE MEDIA, AND WE WILL SEE THIS
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THEY ARE HEDONISTS WHILE THESE
PEOPLE ARE BEING BUILT UP.
THEN TURN INTO PURE TANS WHEN
THEY FALL.
REVERSE THAT.
IT TIES IN NICELY WITH THIS
HORRIBLE CASE OF R. KELLY WHO
ALSO WENT DOWN IN FLAMES OVER A
DOCUMENTARY SERIES AT LIFETIME.
IN JANUARY.
LAST MONTH.
SURVIVING R. KELLY.
SHOULD WE STOP LISTENING TO
THESE PEOPLE?
>> Laura: I AM NOT DEFENDING
ANYONE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH RELIT
GATING SOMEONE'S LIFE.
>> WHEN THEY ARE LEAD.
>> Laura: MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE I
GREW UP LISTENING TO THE
JACKSON-5 AND THRILLER.
IT'S PART OF MY YOUTH.
IT'S PART OF THE YOUTH OF THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
NOW TO SAY THE ARTISTIC PRODUCT
ITSELF IS TOXIC, WE HAVE A LOT
OF SONGS AND ARTISTS THAT WE
BETTER GET BIG SHARPIE PEN AND
GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE SONY
CATALOG.
>> YOU HAVE CHRIS BROWN.
JERRY LEE LEWIS MARRIED HIS
13-YEAR-OLD COUSIN AND BING
CROSBY BEAT THE KIDS.
WE DON'T THINK OF THAT WHEN WE
HEAR WHITE CHRISTMAS.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THIS ENDS.
>> WELL,
>> WEL --
>> THEY PULL DOWN STATUES.
THEY DON'T LET PEOPLE LIVE IN
THE CURRENT TIME.
>> THE MUSIC IS ABOUT US.
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE TIME.
IT CAPTURES A TIME FOR US.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THESE PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU SEE R. KELLY, WE
WATCHED THESE TWO WOMEN LIVING
WITH HIM.
THEY INTERVIEWED WITH GALE KING.
WATCH THIS QUICKLY.
>> HOW DO WE SAY THIS WITHOUT
BEING INAPPROPRIATE?
IS THERE A THREE-WAY
RELATIONSHIP?
DO YOU HAVE A SEPARATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM?
HOW DOES THIS WORK?
>> WELL, BOTH.
WE BOTH HAVE INDIVIDUAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND WE ALL ARE A
FAMILY ALL TOGETHER.
WE HAVE MOMENTS WHERE WE SIT AND
WATCH MOVIES AND GO TO AMUSEMENT
PARKS ALL TOGETHER.
>> I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT GOING
TO MOVIES OR GOING TO PARKS.
IS IT A THREE-WAY SEXUAL
RELATIONSHIP?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL I AM NOT
HERE TO TALK ABOUT MY PERSONAL
LIFE.
I WOULD NEVER SHARE WITH NO ONE
WHAT I DO IN THE BEDROOM.
I'VE AS A WOMAN I AM SURE YOU
WOULD NOT EITHER.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MULTIPLE GIRLFRIENDS.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT.
>> IT IS DIFFERENT.
R. KELLY IS A DEGENERATE.
CONDEMN ON THE FRONT END AND
CHOOSE YOUR ICONS WISELY.
7:30 NIGHT AT MY ALMA MATTER 238
THOMPSON STREET.